big week for campaigners as well now
when we spoke to Carol Gould who's a
mother of the murdered teenager Ellie
Gould just three days ago that's on
Sunday she was hopeful that the
government would significantly increase
sentences for those who violently kill
women we now know thanks to a letter
from Dominic Robb that they're only
planning to add around two years for
aggravating factors but the use of
excessive or gratuitous violence beyond
that necessary to kill or she joins us
now I'm glad to say
um thank you so much for coming on the
program again at such short notice I
wasn't expecting you to be interviewing
you again at three days later but I'm
very glad to have you
um if we can just start if if I may by
if you just remind viewers about what
happened to your daughter Ellie
um so Ellie was dating a fellow student
she was just 17 years old
um it was only a three-month
relationship but
um after a couple of months he became
controlling over her and suffocating and
she decided to end the relationship
um he then came to our house the
following day and he strangled her and
he stabbed her 13 times in the neck
um and then he just walked out of her
house as though nothing had happened
yeah it's just it is shocking and to
this day we still can't quite believe
it's happened
um so we had some hope after the Claire
Wave review that
um Overkill would finally be recognizing
the sentencing because the sense in the
perpetrator got was just 12 and a half
years
um and I was absolutely devastated when
um on Monday I saw the letter that
Dominic Bob had sent to his colleagues
saying that they were considering just
an increase of censusin for two years
you know in one breath they're saying
that
um that they they acknowledge it and the
horror of Overkill and the anguish it
causes to families and then the next
breath they're saying but we're gonna
and then we'll increase sentencing by
two years
[Music]
yeah and I mean it's just it's
heartbreaking all the campaigning we've
got we've been doing myself and Julie
devily to to try and level up this
sentence in between domestic homicides
and murders that happen in the street
and we were really hoping that you know
there were the 10-year difference would
be leveled up but it looks like it's not
going to be much more than two years and
if I could just talk a little bit about
the anguish that you go through as
parents
um we had to visit Ellie in the morgue
and they had to cover up her neck and
her face with bandages and plaster so
that we couldn't see the full extent of
her injuries
pop his parents have a 25-page document
detailing her 112 injuries
that's the anguish and the Heartbreak
that we live with every day knowing how
our beautiful girls were murdered
and you know just add in two years for
that is an absolute insult to us and I
think
Minister arga and Dominic Robb owe it to
us to have their meeting face to face
look in our eyes and explain to us how
they have come up with just adding two
years for the horrific nature of these
crimes
um and I I you know I'd be really
interesting to hear how they have come
up with that figure of just two two
years to add to the sentence
well that's a something that we can
certainly see if it happens or not if
you do get that face-to-face meeting
with those ministers do you feel that
you've been
misled perhaps is perhaps too strong a
word but do you think that you've been
given assurances or hope
that things would have been different
absolutely I mean
we can't quite understand why they're
Consulting on coercive controlling
relationships having a starting point of
25 years
um when 50 of domestic homicides
experience that but 60 of the domestic
homicides experienced Overkill so why
are they not Consulting on that being a
25-year starting point and and what
we've found with these murders is that
you can't rely on the judges to deliver
the correct sentence
um in our case you know the judge took
two years off of Griffith's sentence
just because his grandparents wrote a
character reference because he'd never
been in trouble with the police before
which I think is pretty irrelevant when
you've just committed them as heinous
crime and for his remorse letter well
the details in his remorse letter
um were not genuine remorse he didn't
explain why he did what he did he said I
hope one day I can explain myself well
to me that isn't genuine remorse at all
and for those negligible things he got
two years off his centers yet you flip
it the other way and for the most
horrific violent frenzied attack the
government already prepared to add two
years it's all completely wrong and
that's why we were arguing to have it
actually written into law a 25 year
starting point for Overkill so that
judges can't get it wrong
you talk a bit about the difference
between domestic murders and murders on
the streets and I think it's just quite
important to talk about a little bit
more about what you mean by that do you
think that there has been I guess a
Prejudice perhaps a sort of anti-woman
bias in the system where if a murder is
committed within the home or within a
relationship it's somehow taken less
seriously
yeah totally these murders are not taken
with the seriousness they deserve you
know if you take a knife out in the
street and stab somebody once in the
park the starting point for sentencing
for that is 25 years
um if you obliterate somebody in the
home and very violent friended attack
the starting point for censusin for that
is 15 years and the justification for
that is that you can't prove it was
premeditated which quite honestly is
nonsense because the perpetrator doesn't
need to bring a weapon to the scene to
premeditation because they often live
with the victim they know where the
weapon is and many of these perpetrators
use their hands so you will never proof
premeditation if they're using their
hands because your hands are a weapon
and they travel with you
um it just diminishes their crime it's
insulting to women it's just so wrong
and we really thought this was a
watershed moment with this Claire Wade
with you and all the talk of the
government about between down hard and
violence against women than girls well
this is a bit of disappointment because
they're not are they
um so I think we need to get around the
table with Minister arga and have a
honest and Frank conversation I have
contacted some MPS that I've had
dealings with in the past and the
general feeling is that this is wrong
um my own MP James Gray raised this at
all questions to the Justice Minister
yesterday and I I publicly thank him for
that and I've had some very positive
response from Caroline notes who is
going to um to raise this directly with
Minister Arthur okay well we're going to
keep pursuing your story with you we
it's a privilege to speak to you and I
know you were talking about the thing
that no parent wants to see which is
your child you know with bandages around
her neck and her face but we've been
looking at some beautiful pictures of
your daughter this evening she looks
happy she looks rhodium and you know I
can tell that how loved she was so thank
you so much for being on the program
again we appreciate it thank you for
following it thank you very much safety